is this related at all to what's
happening at skinwalker
yes because remember Skinwalker
was a Native American known area of
unusual phenomenon contact
there's a gentleman named uh Bob Bigelow
Robert Bigelow who I first met at the
Rockefeller Ranch in 1993
who uh along with some of his Sidekicks
uh
Colonel John Alexander and others wanted
to acquire that property and in the
Rancher didn't want to sell it so they
set up a lot of this
uh weird wsfm electromagnetic phenomenon
that was scariest and the guy
relented and eventually sold it it has
since been resold to another person of
course I guess it's been sensationalized
in some TV show but the uh there's a lot
of activity going on underground there
but we were out there about a year and a
little over a year ago and observed uh
late night uh what very much sounds like
under under this facility a Drilling
um and uh building of something deep
underground and my understanding it's
sort of like the um
uh the Brad uh the Bradshaw Ranch in
Sedona that got taken over by and turned
into a black site so I think that the
Skinwalker Ranch has all kinds of weird
phenomenon that has to do with this kind
of experimentation and that it has
nothing to do with what was innately
there prior to so I think this is again
often when there's something quite
interesting happening like that you have
people from who are fronting for the
intelligence Community or being
manipulated by them who then required as
an asset
um and so that you know sort of what's
called capture where it'll get you know
they'll try to capture that and then use
it to their own purposes and whatever is
going on after they get involved it has
a faint resemblance to what was there
prior
to the acquisition so I my understanding
is that we went out there and did
actually a close encounter of the fifth
kind see if I've contact event uh in
June of 2021 very interesting yeah well
no on a Mesa overlooking so we were near
it we weren't on the property so we're
talking in the U inter Basin yeah
well it was on a some private land
adjacent to and sort of above where the
ranch would be if you went down so yeah
but very close
and uh so so I mean you know
nothing all that extraordinary except we
did observe
um this sound of a Drilling and of
course it it reminded me of uh back in
the 80s you know the new agers were
going on about the Taos hum uh and you
know around Taos New Mexico and
um and out in that area of Northern New
Mexico and of course that was the
Bechtel uh nuclear-powered tunneling
machine making the connector between Los
Alamos and the Dulce area which cannot
be accessed from the ground or above but
only from a tunneling uh and that was uh
you know that device was brought on in
the 60s 70s but it's and of course it's
classified it's nuclear powered so
people would not like the idea of some
nuclear powered thing running under
their uh land but that's how you connect
say from Edwards to Nellis or Los Alamos
to Dulce and so it sounds like from one
of I understand and you know that's
happening at the skin walker Ranch
probably connecting out to another
facility like The dugway Proving Grounds
or someplace like that
in Utah dugway is a very key I mean
certainly I think that much more
significant than so-called Area 51 is
this newer underground dumb as they're
called Deep Underground military base
operations out near dugway